and where
[Music]
I hope so
the battery produces 60 wheels of
cheese a day for a total of about
20 thousand wheels per year.
fausto ciao Credito
Emiliano
we are a traditional bank and we are
also an active bank in support of the
producers of Parmigiano Reggiano they already have an
often footballing analogy gen in
stage and eating 3d sex mans and we hope
downs from horus follow safe launches
investment bank
the decision to use the  Parmigiano
Reggiano for this type of
guarantee program is simply due to the fact
that this is the traditionally typical product,
perhaps almost unique in time to this
territory
.  investment of the producer
therefore from the cow to the bank
and cheese bank
[Music]
no I'm brown I'm the ide
actor and performer of this ecological park
[Music]
[Applause]
then observing a movement in nature
that there is the branch that lowers bird
that flies and consequently
the idea arises maybe that movement I say I would
also like to play a game  and after the
moment of avoiding the god of the sky so
seen
[Music]
I can work an hour a
whole day a whole month in the piano
the idea grows that if it is suffering when it is
finished so I look at it
look how beautiful  that I find I did it
well from 40 to 50 games you are never more
sure of course in the greatest virtues
of everything by manual force there are no
mechanisms
if you want to play here you have to push and
sweat
otherwise the game does not move this
is the  'important and the beauty of this
park
[Music]
the parents to show the children
how to play they
go up but in their hearts I am convinced
that they are children again
and it's nice to see if things
[Music]
when walking in the middle of my park  here
s  especially when towards evening towards the
sunset that probes only then I look at myself
my heart widens for having created
something from nothing that will later be
in time
[Music]
in Italy the job and he did it
complete with candle yes  he lifted his
hat he burned the tips burning
the tips the hat evolves and
closing in becomes the rock show
gets stronger and no longer falls many
people lose their hair because barbers
do not know how to cut their hair to burn
the tips this is very important
here  we are at sica barberi accolla the
first beard via di milano it is a traditional barber shop
like a farmer sarah
had earth a jump knows the fabric
once they did their hair these
many important that I do and
hairdresser since I was nine
for nine years now that about it  82
I have been a barber for 73 years once the
barber was a very important thing
now it is very different the barber does not
exist anymore
I have lived a different world  rso after
job you have to do it well do it well it
means to be good at 20 hairs
do not get cut but the
light insults of hundreds of thousands
of love stories that come from all over the world
which is a very beautiful thing i
am giovanna tamassia and i run the club
of juliet in verona
thanks to shakespeare many tourists
visitors come however for the story of
romeo juliet and the letter juliet
come
from almost a hundred years ago in verona it is a
phenomenon that I have seen
an increase especially in the 90s
the letters have become thousands and
thousands  in all languages and it was then
hat we thought of creating clubs
and juliet this
roup of people who are dedicated to th
s particular activity to answe
translate and archive the thous
nds of letters in all languages of th
are about 10 thousand every year to whi
h  the keeper of Juliet's tomb
Hector Solimani began to answer and collect
the first letters that  and he
found in this tourist site that it was
precisely Juliet's tomb and he
began to respond by signing Juliet
's secretary therefore to the
tradition born in this way and
continues today that he writes to
Juliet normally has a
love problem and therefore
asks asks  an advice tells
its
story we try to answer in the best
possible way give the right advice or in
any case a word of friendship of
understanding the concept of love
I think it is universal in the letters
we can see
from what people write how much
love  nevertheless lived as one
of the most important things in life ever
are about 30 years because we do
this job that we read letters
but love has not changed the importance of the
feeling of love remains in
the hands and remains unchanged both over
time and  in space with all the countries
of the world
[Music]